remember space is your best friend you
don't want to kill your best friend to
you
[Music]
all right so we have three blocks that
are very similar in measurements in
terms of their size if I take this
duplicate it down they're very similar
not quite but they're very similar okay
and they're butting up against each
other and it's trapping all the space in
here
yeah like ah let me breathe a little bit
it's almost like you built a house and
we're looking from a floor plan like
from top down we have this courtyard up
here in the top left and we have this
courtyard in the bottom right but the
people are playing up here can't play
with the people at the bottom right
we've given them no space like how do we
move from one place to the other the
egress and ingress in and out of space
the flow the air the energy the Chi
we're like blocking it up so we kinda
have to figure something out there okay
Naoko do you have any thoughts on on
this layout remember space is your best
friend you don't want to kill your best
friend do you you don't want to kill
that space that is giving the breathing
room for those big beautiful nice tight
typography in the middle of the page so
by putting the journal for graphic
design at the bottom right where we're
suffocating the space and then we're
doing the same thing by putting
january/february at the top left corner
let's take those out and if we cover
those we can see how we can we can
breathe ah look at that
oh I can't breathe now and then if we
also cover january/february just
temporarily the to that the height of
the two negative spaces are almost the
same size let's see if we can decrease
one of them and increase the other one
to create of a more asymmetrical dynamic
layout and how would we do this
maybe we'll push it down a little bit
okay maybe we'll make resonate this is
two sizes too weights right maybe we can
take advantage um okay that's even
better that's even nice nice Chris
beautiful beautiful we can even take the
whole area of eight and the rest of the
body copy and pushed
a little bit now oh no didn't work yeah
it didn't work how about this how about
we protect features and the remaining of
the body copy and push it up the whole
entire body copy uh-huh and the list but
just just see okay it's working but then
we're creating the staircase effective
Rio staircase so why don't we do this
why don't we push 8 all the way up and
then take the whole entire body copy
bring it down and see what happens to
that what do you think Chris no knots
playing the piano I know exactly what
you're doing I can't really exactly what
you're doing and you're trying to like
free up some space so I have some
thoughts on how to do this please okay
let's try so I thought we were off to a
good thing by saying we free up space up
at the top here by pushing the type down
we can still read it what if we were to
either push it this way or push it this
way and just free up some space now nice
take one just for a minute I know that
we just told you like the tops of letter
forms are easier to read true but we're
just exploring the layout right now and
so now look what we've done we've opened
up the space
we haven't changed practically anything
just yet except for to shift the crop if
you will okay like this is what
photographers do they look through the
frame and they find the part that's
interesting and that's the picture that
they take on you in this case you're
looking at your own layout your subject
and you're gonna just gonna crop it
differently now by doing this I think we
give ourselves a little bit more freedom
before we've talked about how to create
something that feels evenly uneven like
it has it going up bend it down kind of
up a kind of mountaintop kind of vibe
versus the shape that we had before
that's the before and this is the after
right so we can try now maybe to take
this and lower it and see if we can
create something that's got a little bit
nicer rhythm so when we talk about space
if we take this and we separate a little
bit like what
pants and we want to explore all these
things so when you're doing this layout
at home kind of just look at your layout
to see what else that you can do so I
think milk is instinct to push this all
the way out was a good one I just don't
know how far we can push it out and this
is also the problem with all uppercase
because the forms are very blocky it's
heavier and I think you did this on
purpose to kind of create the skyline if
you will it's like a vertical building
it's very blocky or as upper and
lowercase letters they have I guess man
I can't find it they have more
interesting forms that are easier to
read they feel a little less rigid I
think there's still problems with this
so the last thing I'm gonna do right now
is I'm going to take this whole thing
and I told you guys before too you can't
change the dimension of the page but you
can't change the size of the type and
this type is probably a little bit
Olympic site it could stand to be
reduced a little bit so I'm gonna reduce
it down I think every time we make one
of these decisions kind of just start to
get a sense like oh space is starting
over like I can't breathe yeah nice job
nice job good reason it's important for
milk of debris okay if you're enjoying
these critiques inspired by the work you
see and I want to get better at layout
and design for print web film or
television we have a course available on
our site that is designed just for you
it will help you to learn the rules of
typography how to create contrast
control focal points achieve
asymmetrically beautiful layouts how to
critique your own work keyboard
shortcuts and include my personal tips
on how to build an asset library so you
can design at the speed of thought as an
added bonus students who enrolled in the
course can participate in future
critiques get updates as a release them
and a time lapse video of me working on
layouts not available anywhere else you
can jump in anytime work at your own
pace and take your typography skills to
the next level that's it for me I hope
to see you in the future
you
[Music]
[Applause]